okay thanks for being here and singing
your song ain't going down since Sun
comes up with me I was very nervous
about it because it's a wordy song man
there's a lot of where it's so wordy
song I might have messed up a couple too
right we're singing love people every
day I do sing a song requested by
someone in that's my studio audience so
are you ready to find out who requested
your song oh I would love to okay all
right
so where's Devon yeah since that song is
older than you are
[Laughter]
music last card I'm listening to you
guard since I was an infant and actually
it's funny connection to that song is
that about three years ago I met my now
husband and my parents do each other and
so that we connected instantly but then
that we were texting all the time and
that Sunday he invited me on our first
date to the LA Zoo and of course he had
a truck so I thought fitting let me put
this song on so I went ahead and I put
this song on nice donated him down to
the zoo and he was so impressed I knew
every word to that song he says I'm
impressed my superpower and here we are
married four months and I love course
music if you don't you're dumb literally
the greatest catalogue ever of music I
can't even believe your career it's I'm
so jealous it's so I mean I'm so happy
for you
just kidding it's so hard felt it's so
inspired it's just so so good
where are Wes and Katie at all right
okay oh hi
we're all good we're good
we have a slight connection oh yeah
where do I know you from we went to your
concert in December of 2017 and we made
a sign at one of your concerts and you
called us up to the front and our sign
said working on a full house boy or girl
oh the gender-reveal
yes is that brother this is baby Brooks
[Applause]
yeah they were just finding out they
what she just found out she was pregnant
and so there's a sign back there it says
two of a kind working on a philosophy
would we'd already played earlier in the
show late at the beginning yet so I'm
sitting there but I'm going why in the
world is he still holding it up and then
they had this envelope or something with
it yes all right the moment Garth reveal
I didn't wanna interrupt him I like the
story we go through you got this mom yes
Garth revealed the gender of Wes and
Katie's baby was captured on camera
check this out
[Applause]
gross so if it's a glance impressive
it's a girl that's right
extremely happy for you because I'm
happy three of these
oh my gosh all right where's Chris
where's Krista are you right oh hi you
have a bowtie on you cute thing okay
thank you so why does guards music mean
so much to you I first became a fan when
I was 14 I saw you in concert absolutely
went with some people and I you know and
I've seen you about a dozen more than a
dozen times now oh yeah so my very first
concert and actually my last concert
that I saw was you you your songs just
have helped me throughout my life there
was a time in my life when I just I felt
stuck you know I was in a dead-end job
with an overbearing manager and it was
affecting my relationship at work and
everybody else and I just was not a good
person to be with and I remember going
to your benefits concert in 2007 for the
fires yeah for the southern cow and
remember I you sang the river and I just
started crying okay like I've already
been holding it back let's just hug it
out
[Applause]
that song I mean just movie to to quit
that job and get out at California
altogether you know I moved to a
different state put myself in a good
place and and ever since then that song
just has been a catalyst for for change
for very sweet yeah and right now I'm
kind of going through that same moment
so
[Applause]
and it is such a great song and a name
for a child I'm just saying river people
it's my little girl's name if you don't
know um we're just naming all our kids
after music oh thank you people love
meeting you so have I mean I know this
because I'm one of them but have you
ever just completely lost your mind and
like goofed out over one of your idols
all the time yeah every time Trisha
Yearwood walks through that door you
know I'm a nerd for her voice is like
the sound of crystal well the crazy
thing is to award you're only as good as
the people's names are on them
compliments and only good as the people
that give them oh no no you're you're a
freak
you're a freak of nature everybody in
the business knows that you have no
stealing year so for you to say that
about her she would sit here and say
like George Strait and cuz you know I've
always wanted me to I know she got a
picture of him up and in the dressing
room back there James Taylor yeah he's
one of the dressier yeah James James
Taylor he was supposed to be at a thing
we were doing a thing for the Christmas
at the White House and he's not there
it's it's it's freezing outside playing
is everybody's wonder where James is but
James is just there he's just not on
location so I start playing the song
that we're gonna sing and the next thing
I knew I heat up and I hear his voice
but the problem is now Fatboy Slim's
playing James Taylor yeah James is
looking at you and you're like
everything just becomes one bone all the
sudden like I don't even know if I could
play this and he was always so sweet yes
good man but you know what I found out
the coolest ones and the biggest
superstars are always the sweetest amen
Dolly's like that dolly Siva
they're all good girl yeah I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this